hello everyone our guru drew his game
against vastly bunch of today and
unfortunately he did lose his game
yesterday against divine choke and this
means he's out of the competition for
the World Cup
Vaslav a joke is going to the
quarterfinals so very nice success for
vastly but as Amish Gary is an excellent
player it would only be fair to show one
game where he well completely destroys
his opponent as this is something you
don't usually see in Gary's games as I
did say yesterday a giri doesn't win a
lot of his games but he doesn't really
lose a lot of them either so it's really
it's really a real treat when Gary
decimates someone and this game was
played in 2012 it was played in a rapid
tournament in Beijing China gear is
playing with the white pieces against
Alexander motors of each with the black
pieces so let's see this game it's well
if you gave me a hundred guesses I would
never say that here we played this game
we have d4 Knight to s6 c4 e6 Knight to
f3 d5 where g3 and D captures on c4 and
Bishop to G 2 so the cattle and opening
and well here black has a number of
options he can go Bishop d7 he can go G
Bishop to b4 check c5 is an option but
as this is a rapid game murasa which
played b5 gira place a four he wants to
break up this structure immediately we
have c6 Knight to e5 no not allowing
black to play Knight to e7 he's
attacking that well c6 pawn twice so we
have Knight to d5 this stops the bishops
attacked opponent c6 we have castles by
Gary and a6 and here we have a capture
some b5 C keep C capture some b5 n b3
now again going for for that c4 pawn
trying to break a break black's pawn
structure we have a seek out for some b3
queen capture some b3 and Bishop to b7
we have e4 by Gary attacking this knight
on d5
we have Knight to f6 and now as black
king is still in the center gear goes
for the aggressive d5 and okay Mirage
plays Bishop to d6 and here we have a
move that well you wouldn't expect from
Geary
but also which is right the castle here
everything is in place but Geary doesn't
allow this he plays Knight captures on
f7 attacking the Queen the rook the
bishop and b6 and well like it doesn't
really have a better move than to
capture this night so we have King
captures on f7 and we have D captures on
e6 over to check and the queen is
protecting this pawn on e6 and well you
can't really play a move like King to g8
for example because you get a 7 and this
is well pretty much this is winning the
Queen here
so after this D captures on e6 check we
have King to e8 and give it plays d5 and
this is a double attack on the bishop on
d6 and also on the knight on f6 and also
this is attacking this Bishop on b7 so
it's pretty you know it's not weird to
wonder is this entire attack based on
the fact that this Bishop on b7 is
undefended who knows but also which
plays Bishop captures on g2 and we have
it captures on f6 and already this is
move 17 giri has a pawn on e6 and
opponent f6 and this is very very
dangerous again black can't castle here
because a 7 is coming so in this
position we have Queen captures on f6
and here okay gear captures the bishop
King kept forcing g2 and we have Queen
captures on a1 and well okay what are
you gonna play here I mean white is
offering a full rook so Morris which
captures that he plays Queen captures on
a1 and we have Bishop to b2 and now with
an attack on the Queen we have Queen to
a for offering the exchange of Queens
but of course here is a rogue down so he
plays Queen to f3 and this is a very
nice move it stops black from castling
it also attacks this rook and a8
so
well what does more rows of each play
here Melissa which is up a whole rook
here and well it is a rap game and he
does have to figure out what to play
here and probably the best move here
would be Queen to see to order an attack
on this Bishop here on b2 but Melissa we
decided to play a rook to a7 and well
this is preventing white from captured
broken a8 and also it's protecting Queen
to f7 check so it seems like a pretty
decent move but give her here here plays
a rook to c1 and he's threatening rock
the c8 check so um Rosie stop says he
plays King to d8 and well how do you
continue this attack with white it's
it's it's not a very easy move to find
but you continue this attack would white
by actually continuing the attack and
get replaced Bishop to f6 with check and
again it's very I'm really not used to
Geary playing like this as this is a
fantastic game now we have Bishop to f6
check and well can you capture this
bishop with G captures on f6 let's see
what happens if he does this if G
captures on f6 you get Queen captures on
f6 would check and well this rock is
covering this C file this point here is
protecting d7 so the King can't really
move only move black and plays really
well
King to e8 although this isn't really an
option you have Bishop d7 and rook to e7
and if for example Bishop d7 you get
Queen captures on h8 with check and this
doesn't just win back the rook it's also
an unstoppable checkmate in one because
it's still the Ken the King can go to
the C file d7 is covered only move his
Bishop to f8 and now Queen captures on
f8 is instant checkmate so after this
Bishop f6 check idea by Gary Morris
which of course doesn't have the option
of capturing the bishop he tried Bishop
to e7 and here we have a queen to d5
check by Geary and well again what do
you play here
you're definitely if possible if you
don't want to give back any
pieces so if King te8 you get rocked the
ch-check and you don't really have a
move here better to d8 and ro capture
sandy eight this is checkmate ff7
squares covered by this point so after
Queen to d5 check more Rosa which had to
play Knight to d7 this is preventing the
check and now well in this position you
do have to find a find an interesting
move and when I first saw this position
I thought well this is a rapid game of
course morosa which probably played
something like Queen to c6
but if Queen to c6 threatening checkmate
on c8 morosely which actually place
simply Bishop captures on f6 and already
why it has nothing here black is
defending and the black is even better
in this position so in this position
after this Knight d7 idea
Gary had to find a winning move and it's
actually a pretty silent move it's well
gamer is down a rook
so simply Bishop to d4 and this is now
attacking this rook and what do you play
here for black probably the best move
that the engine gives the screen capture
this bishop on d4 because the rock can't
go to b7 he can't go to a8 o queen is
covering a8
but more rows which played rock to c7
trying to exchange this rockin c1 and
give her simply played Queen to eight
check and well there there is no there
is no defense against this in this
position Alexander Monro so which
resigned the game on the move is like
for example night to b8 sorry only move
is night to b8 and after Queen captures
here rocked c8 and why little rook
captures or queen get person c8 this is
checkmate
but yeah we didn't see this after Queen
to eight Alexander more searchers end
the game and this is well this is
definitely the most exciting game I've
ever seen played by Gary as I did see a
lot of Gary's games but this is simply
this is simply beautiful as whenever
someone
as of this moment that well Garry's
games are boring your new you know Gary
only plays for a draw I'll just show
them this 2012 game against Alexander
morozova Chen Beijing China as this is
this is a beauty so yeah this is the
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
and I will I would like to thank
Alistair MacLean Jason green and John
Erhart for a contribution to my channel
I really appreciate it thank you very
much and yeah enlisted thank all for
watching and I will see you soon